yeah all right we kind of started all
right it's giving me the thumbs up this
is gonna be really difficult for me
because I really like to pace and I
can't pace because I have to stand right
here with this microphone is I'm sure my
hands will start moving a lot more
because of that's bear with them
my name is Glen I'm a program manager on
the donut team specifically on a speed
mm-hmm asp net core team to much pre
talked and talking merrily yes so
specifically on the SPD core team I've
been working on it since the very
beginning basically there was a little
bit of prototyping stuff done before I
joined but otherwise have been there
since the beginning of the thing that is
today known as asp net core back then it
had very different names and more
specifically lately in the last kind of
I don't know a little while a couple of
years maybe I have had a focus on what
is p.net core or what most to give it a
more general name what more could net
core on the server do to help you guys
building things like micro services
things like cloud native cloud native
applications more generally and micro
services in specifically so what we're
going to talk about is we're going to
talk about some stuff that we've got
today we've talked about swagger health
checks tool wing he should be client
factory I'm going to talk about some
stuff that we're gonna have support for
tomorrow and how you can build those
things out today we're gonna talk about
application models for message queues
and how you might be able to build those
today and use those today leveraging
everything we've got then I'll show you
what's coming so let's make that better
and easier and harder faster stronger
better and then later we're going to
talk about G RPC metrics so this
timeline is both the order that we're
gonna talkin it and probably the order
that you'll see it come out from
Microsoft the further through the slide
deck we get the more tenuous and weird
and the last two slides are literally
from a design meeting we had this
morning so you can take them as you will
so I got a mandate from my bosses I have
I have bosses like everybody else
and it went something like make a is
peanut core great for building
native apps especially for micro
services and I said what does that even
mean
and they said micro services what do we
even pay you for go work it up or
something like that and they said okay
sure thing yes their boss and we I so we
started to talk about things like this
we're talking about these these top this
top list of stuff here MTA COO worker
event-driven CQRS micro services if you
go to Azure Docs and you say how do I
build a cloud thing they'll give you
this list and I'll say these are the
most common things we see people doing
we're making the best out of utilizing
Azure to gain the best that that's the
stuff that they can I'm like oh great
that's cool I spin a car it kind of
really only works best with that top one
end here that's probably a problem right
like in terms of like the core stuff
that's in the box right it works best
with that it's kind of where it came
from
works okay with all the other everything
that's in this list you can move we've
done that call all right we have this
stuff all over the ecosystem all over
the community we build stuff everybody's
build stuff but it was best for that
first thing and kind of okay for
everything else not something that our
team had ever really focused on making
first class so the first thing was like
hey let's let's look at all these things
that seems pretty obvious people
building cloud native or building this
if clarity is important let's make that
better or more first-class and more
supportive and then there's a bunch of
different principles and concerns that
you end up seeing if your building cloud
native apps you're decentralized
observability becomes a really big
problem when you've got you've when
you've got 500 micro services running in
a cluster and something's going wrong
it's a lot harder to see what that thing
is and where that thing is then when
you've got just one big application with
a fairly consistent log stream coming
out of it all right so metrics
Diagnostics logging you start seeing
things especially in micro services
polyglot assistance and polyglot
languages like all different sorts of
languages and different databases all
within the same same application space
go on is the day of one big sequel
server database of one big article
database with like it really big with
the big data to you at a big services to
here and a big uit right that sort of
stuff you can kind of make you can make
work here and you can port it to the
cloud but it's not what you do if you're
designing for the cloud up front which
is kind of what we're talking
about here right and then you see async
communication designing for failure
suddenly mean time to recovery became a
really important metric that we didn't
know about before not people did
necessarily care about before things
like that now API seemed to be pretty
common to all these types of
architectures and things it seems that
if you're gonna build one of these types
of things you probably got a bunch of
api's probably and so we said okay what
is an API look like then in in this asp
net core world and we started and I
started to look at that we're gonna look
at it today and we're gonna show the
today's stuff like how did we how did we
just to begin with how did we just start
making API is better because in almost
all these application types you care
about API is right it's a few people
nineteen they're like yeah I like me
some API it seems like a pretty good
deal yeah yeah okay so I did a file new
web application and it's apparently
deciding to spin projects successfully
created but I'm still going to wait I'm
not really sure what it's doing but
apparently it's apparently it's decides
to do hmm hey it was okay it's a good
thing we were waiting for Visual Studio
it's alright okay all right so this is
pretty standard have you guys have seen
this before actually first hands is
anybody just not done in the asp.net
core okay great some of this might have
been really confusing if you hadn't done
anything before because I I wasn't gonna
go over lots of basics okay so let's
talk about this this is standard values
controller you do f5 you get some you
get an API alright cool so the first
thing I started to look at if I'm
building a micro Service say well this
thing doesn't seem really useful I don't
think I'm gonna have a dub dub dub root
anywhere anytime soon cuz I don't really
care about UI well I kind of care about
what's in this values controller cuz
that's where I'm gonna write code kind
of unfortunately it's in a subfolder
let's like fix that so let's move this
out we don't care about lots of
controllers because it's a micro service
right I'm only gonna do a small amount
of stuff so let's just delete that we
don't really need
is that that seems fine what are we
going in values controller let's see
hello I'm out oh look it's just going
like this - is instead of instead of
actually zooming out this is this is a
this is a great this is a great set of
demos good job good job windows damn
look at that and I better close that
because I just realized it's opening
otherwise someone will start talking to
me okay so let's open up this and say
well I values controllers kind of okay
but this API / it's kind of a no
holdover from when I was going to be
mixing UI and API into my same map so
I'm not super concerned about keeping
that around what else there's a lot of
stuff here that we don't it isn't
necessarily useful before Maya cloud
native micro service so let's let's
continue on this journey of like turning
this into this application into
something that's actually good before
for the foundation that we're looking
for right okay let's jump into program
CS what do we got
okay so berry berry dorans if any of you
watch berry dorans talk he will tell you
that everything it's in this bit is
useless infinite in a service not
useless but like mostly useful if you're
gonna have UI and API and the same thing
which is kind of what you did a lot with
Web API not so much what you're doing in
this world HT th STS is mostly useful
for a browser or only useful for a
browser and if you're gonna do HTTP and
somebody like your clients aren't humans
so if your client talks to your API and
it sends a little token over HTTP it's
kind of already too late so your API
then redirecting to HTTPS probably
doesn't provide the most value so what
we probably want to do is just do HTTP
and died by HTTP for your API is and
force everybody to use it that way so
the redirection of stuff let's remove
that make it a lot simpler which is nice
because if we're gonna have a micro
service gonna have lots like small
amounts of code it seems good to be able
to focus just on what we care about
right cool so now that I've like deleted
ever had a bunch of stuff and complained
about everything that's been in the box
for so many just so much so long let's
talk about what we can add what are we
what have we done
to help out that makes this useful first
of all does everybody like this do you
think this would be in better like file
nude for what you expect to get from
micro-services it's a few nods people
like yeah if I did file new and go there
that seems likely to be okay cool
alright so first thing let's talk about
health checks if you're gonna build a if
you're gonna build a an application that
has lots of its let's risk zooming once
more and hope it works this time so that
you guys can see I don't want anybody
thinking like man I can't see anything
this guy's doing so we're gonna go
services that out of health checks oh so
happy and then we're gonna say app dot
use health checks and we're gonna say
slash this year it takes a string and
optionally it also takes a port number
which is interesting so like I could say
here I'm gonna add this health check
it's gonna be on slash health but only
if you talk to my Apple on port 9000 and
then I would tell Kestrel to listen on
port 9000 as well and that way you could
do things like play firewall blocking so
we can only be accessed from internal or
something like that rather than trying
to do a North on your health check the
idea we have for health checks is like
let's say you're good if you're building
an API and you're gonna have a load
balancer and your load balancer is gonna
balance across several api's your load
balance has probably got that mechanism
built in to be able to ping those
different api's to see when they're out
what endpoint are you going to point to
that - right you need to make something
up if you have if everybody is gonna do
that in the new world which generally
you are if you're running on any if
you're running on kubernetes or any
modern cloud platform you probably have
some of this stuff built in so we should
give you something to help you out with
that that's what this is alright and
especially if you're in containers port
mappings really easy so port we wanted
to make it so that you could restrict it
to a specific port really easy which is
why it's built this way you're not built
in some other way it has a lot of it has
a service and a system in here for you
to do things like so the idea here is
you can add add health checks and then
you might be able to go like a database
check all right and then the health the
health check will only return healthy if
your application can communicate with
your database that way you could do
things like have kubernetes rolling
updates where your update will only
deploy
you can talk to your date your
communities will only send traffic to
your app if it's capable of talking to
the database for example right seems
nice so we wanted to build that in what
else have we got we want to be able to
say app dot we want some swagger does
everything anybody everybody know what
swagger is everybody nods fantastic does
anybody here think that we shouldn't add
swagger to this thing that it's not
gonna be useful
yeah mark I don't know man okay so use
swagger so we're going to in this case
we're gonna use swagger UI he likes to
put his hand up whenever anybody asks
that queer those sorts of obvious candy
questions because you know that's the
way he is asp net core does anybody use
den swag before whole bunch of you other
people of you swashbuckle they've got
most people saying yeah okay good I'm
installing stalling n swag and then the
code that you're right here is you go
apatite's use swagger no it's my package
manager console dead - look at that
today is the best day to write code on
this laptop apparently we're going to
edit ICS bridge right now boom and swag
swashbuckle I don't remember what
version this is because I didn't check
because I was going to use the you know
the built-in tooling for that here's a
fun tip for you all if you press tab you
can search right here then anybody know
that fantastic I just taught you
something I'm pretty happy pretty happy
about that what I don't know is if this
is a problem with the Internet in
general then this talks gonna go real
bad right okay so well that thing's
making up its mind we're going to go
whether or not it's going to you whether
while it's making up his mind whether or
not the Internet is going to work we're
gonna go here
gonna say don't you get we're gonna go
packages and we're gonna go in swag
we're gonna say dot asp net core oh
there's a number fantastic oh look at
that look all that he was copy it and
now magically it's in my CS proj file
how that happen I'm guessing this
command line finished look at that
fantastic okay now we need a using
statement and we're gonna add we're
gonna add swagger with API swell we're
gonna add swagger with API Explorer then
we'll add this is like a there was one
there I don't know if you guys mess saw
it go past it was like add swagger UI
three with API Explorer this letter
probably merged these two commands we're
gonna put them in because I figure some
of you at least are probably gonna go
and want to go if app dot is developer
Debbie's development around this thing
so we'll do that now we'll one last
thing now that we've got swag now that
we've got swagger in here another thing
that's kind of unfortunate about
pressing f5 in an API project is you
know really want to actually execute
your gets when you're running your app
so it seems unfortunate that you have to
do that so we're gonna change this to
swagger now right most of all of this
stuff that I'm doing here by the way I
do intend to ship as a template so that
we can just do file new and you're a
template looks like this so that you can
go anybody who thinks that's a bad idea
you should come talk to me at the end
cuz you might not have much time if you
think it is
I expect to ship it as a as like a
template on new get that you can
download and choose optionally and then
eventually with based on what everybody
thinks work with everybody and then
eventually we'll make it the default and
put it in the box or not put it in the
box as as whatever whatever the case may
be
it looks like Visual Studio decided to
download three copies of Windows whilst
it was whilst it was building my
application so you'll have to pardon how
long this is taking what we're gonna do
here is now that we're gonna run the
application is going to open up swaggy
UI you'll see that this wagga you are
you guys have all seen that so I'm gonna
stone in on a couple of very specific
things the first one apparently it
didn't even run at all after all of that
the first thing that we're going to do
look at the returns code so what are you
guys expecting here when I look at the
you've seen values controller before
right you get your receptor 200 it
returns a string yeah we can try it out
we can execute it I'm not going to do
that you guys have done that before so
there's nothing super new here that you
couldn't do before health checks is kind
of new I've showed some people in swag
however there's another thing that you
can do which is in 2.2 you can do
something like this you can add this
assembly attribute to say API
conventions type of default API
conventions now this does a few
interesting things and what we're gonna
do here is I'm gonna run my application
now for most of this stuff that I'm
talking about by the way that's - one or
two - if you go to John Galloway's talk
later
he'll go a lot deeper I'm skimming it
the stuff that's important for this kind
of talk to get into some more deeper
stuff but yeah all that stuff will be
available or if you watch like the
dotnet Kampf talks and things like that
from last week you'll see it so if you
open up this thing the get values ID yet
get values are still the same it just
returns 200 but get values of ID it says
it returns a 200 it returns a 404
somehow it has this JSON object that he
knows it's going to return call a
problem detail does anybody know what
problem details are no not really a
couple of people are nodding but not
really so problem details are an RFC for
a way to for a standard way of returning
an error condition from an API that can
be kind of machine readable so by
implementing these conventions by saying
I want you to use these conventions and
you can write your own sets of these
conventions we've said we assume all
your api's could probably have an error
so they probably all return event
problem details so there you go we
assume that if you've got a method
called gap that accepts an ID you're
probably going to return a 404 because
what happens if the ID doesn't exist you
probably can return a problem detail and
you're probably going to return a
success status code if it's there right
so we're just going to give you all
those attributes so you don't need to
add them to your type right seems
reasonable and so that's why when you go
look at that now you see a bunch of
extra data now I'm not going to because
I because I had a little bit of extra
time trying to get my machine working
there's an analyzer that you can add to
your project as well and it'll give you
squigglies to say
oh you're returning a status code here
that your convention doesn't say that
you're gonna return control dot here and
we'll add that attribute to your method
for you we don't want it to be like
naggy though so like it doesn't
necessarily always say that and as you
saw here I'm not actually returning a
404 from any of these things even though
it said I was returning a 404 so if the
convention says that you're gonna return
a type will tell you we won't
necessarily give you a thing saying go
do this because it's not necessarily in
general we believe it's okay to over
duck over document the types of status
codes that you're going to return so we
kind of are on that's on the side of
that at least for now you guys can tell
us what you think I'm always interested
to hear your opinion about this type of
feature this kind of experience of
providing like conventions and analyzers
in tooling so the visual studio helps
you attribute your API is the way you
want is kind of a new area for us so
giving you some help for that there's
also some other things right so if you
do things like say like if model dot is
valid if you if you say model dot is
valid in here
there's a check where a really common
piece of code you'll always say it's
like if model is valid
like check model state return bad
request if the model is invalid if you
guys have all written that before if you
do that and you have these analyzers
it'll now go gray and you're getting
squiggly saying remove this code asp net
has a filter that'll do this for you so
you don't need to and then you can
choose to turn the filter off if you
don't want that behavior or you just lit
up the gladder go and the analyzer tells
you there's no other real way for us to
guide you down that path of where we've
added a feature to remove this common
pattern that everybody has to do but how
do we tell everybody so now that we've
shipping analyzers we can do that sort
of work it's in our blog post you should
check it out again let's let's go back
so yeah and I and I a template for
helping you out would probably look
something like this does that seem good
yeah everybody's like yeah that sounds
great that's what I would probably
they're probably the first several
things that I would do so we talked
about swagger API conventions and
analyzers I didn't show this but it'll
be in some of the other stuff that I
talked about like Galloway's talk one of
the very first time I gave this demo was
to the head of dev dev Julia and I
pressed fi I said okay we've got an API
great f5 and it 404 because it didn't go
API slash values and that seems like a
problem don't you agree
it'll be nice if when you f5 didn't
Visual Studio it gave you something new
something more useful than a browser to
browse your API that you don't really
use browsers for so part of that is
giving you a swagger UI experience part
of that is we're going to experiment
with a command-line tool to be able to
NAV once you've got swagger we'll give
you like a directory tree you've got to
navigate around your application you've
gotta execute gets you'll be able to do
a post and it'll open and editor with a
premade post for you whole bunch of
stuff like that it'll be kind of an
amalgamation with a bunch of other tools
that you tend to go and install anyway
is it different
as a developer kind of mash them all
together hopefully give you something
useful that you could use as a pretty
good like kind of way to test and
replicate around your app health checks
we talked about HTTP client factory we
added because once you've built this API
and you want something to talk to that
API then you also start talking about
resiliency in cloud native applications
when you look at HTTP client factory it
manages a lot how many of you how many
of you keep HTTP client factory around
forever you just keep one just you can
do one up and you keep it around you
keep reusing it it's ok put your hand up
don't be shy
good how many of you how many of you new
one up whenever you need one you just
knew our patient to be quiet and use it
throw it away dispose of it cool ok
great
all of you are in some way doing it
wrong so HTTP client factory will work
around most of those problems for you I
can go into lots of details about it at
the end if you want to go into it and
that's not that big a deal but it but it
can be nice but the biggest thing that
HTTP client factory does it effectively
gives you outgoing middleware so you
have incoming middleware in asp net core
HT require a factory gives your outgoing
middleware so you can look at HTTP
requests that you're going to make and
do stuff to them so one of the things
you could do is wrap them in a poly
retry policy so that you can always
automatically retry
right well you could build in a circuit
breaker well you could have the URI have
the thing that you give it go check do
like manual DNS right you could request
slash HTTP slash foo or even just like
foo and then in the outgoing middleware
it can go like ask console what the hell
what it is that you meant by that and
you'll get an IP address back and in the
actual request will be against grab the
address well that sort of stuff is
possible with HTTP client factory
and then we're working on a hasty client
factory has shipped repple has not yet
most HTM client factory is the only
thing on this list that's kind of
definitely ships already the rest of
this stuff is already in preview you can
go get it
the last thing that isn't in preview yet
but we're doing is client Jen so once
you've got your swagger doc we're gonna
provide some msbuild stuff so that you
could add in swag to your client project
and it'll generate a c-sharp or a
typescript client to be able to automate
going and talking to that back-end API
alright cool but what about when I want
to do something like this and I don't
care about your HTTP
what about message queues background
work as a cool web scale if you want to
do something like this you can do
something like this it sounds great does
anybody doing things like this now you
know I've got my web app and it just
puts a message on a queue and then it
gets back to the user as quick as
possible then you have several back-end
workers right everyone's like yeah of
course I try I've tried to use the cloud
thanks ok let's talk about that I didn't
need to do that because anyway let's go
back here let's close this web
application and let's go to this
background queue worker console
application this is just a file new
console app I use connect or console app
but it has this worker queue like open
that's all I've done so let's dislike
this so let's talk about what we want to
do here what we want to do is we want to
say connect to we're gonna use Azure
storage queues we're going to pull
message off of that queue that's open
that worker queue there we're gonna
pretend like we do some work to it and
that's that's it seems simple enough
right cool so we're gonna connect to the
connector storage we're gonna like grab
a message we need to do the business to
it whatever that is like whatever your
business stuff is we're gonna like we
probably need to do something like
handle bad messages like if you've got
like a message that fails five times
then it's probably not going to work a
sixth time we probably need to do
something about that probably be nice if
it logged every now and then probably be
nice if you could get there like what
the queue name was from config right
cool now if your ASP decor application
is the thing that's going to talk to
this API it'll be kind of nice you've
already sorted out config and logging
and all that sort of stuff in your asp
net core app right kind of nice if you
could do the same thing with your work
with this web cue thing right but you
can't right hmm you can excellent you
can indeed you're at you can because
that was a trick question of course a
quick strict statement in this case so
how many of you here know what oh man
package manager console again okay how
many of you know what generic host is a
few of you good you might know where
this is going then okay
install package Microsoft dot extensions
diet hosting right so Microsoft
extensions hosting is where the generic
host stuff lives I'm also going to
install Microsoft extensions logging dot
console because we're going to do some
console logging I left out extensions
thank you everybody you guys are great
I'll give you a green no doubt oh no man
ok
Microsoft extensions logging console and
then I think I typed this a thousand
times this week without any Microsoft
extensions configuration environment
variables if I can't spell like
extensions what chance do I have of
spelling environment variables I ask you
ok so I installed Microsoft extensions
hosting I just thought I stole the
console logging I installed environment
variables coffee so now I'm gonna go
over host
junk junk via host equals new host
builder alright and we're gonna control
dot our way to glory I'm gonna use add
the appropriate usings we're gonna say
configure logging this looks familiar
right this is look familiar to people
yeah there's a few nods yeah if you've
only used like asp.net core since we had
like create default host builder
you might not have seen as much of this
before but it's trust me it's happening
at the beginning of your application
then we're gonna say like C goes to C
dot add environment variables all right
and then we controlled our way to glory
here we say BAM and now I don't think
this one works for some reason which
I'll need to complain to somebody about
in that it didn't that the control dot
doesn't work to tell me to add this
particular using just unfortunate okay
now that was completely unnecessary
build but thank you okay so I've had in
logging I've had a configuration that
was like two of the things over here
that's good that's done right and then I
need to actually like we can build this
and then down here we can say host our
run there's a host or an async and if I
wanted to go add languidly to slang
stuff I could do that in here but you
know so then what I'm gonna do here is
what the Jeanette what this host this is
what we call the generic host we call a
generic because there's more generic
than web it's basically the same pattern
that you've had for asp net core without
anything specific to web you know and
what it does is where the web host is
pre-configured to boot kestrel and do
web stuff this is not all it does is if
you have any services called hosted
services in your application it will run
them so what we're going to do is say
add hosted service and we're gonna say
cue worker or something like that right
seems like a good enough name and then
we controlled our way the glory again we
say we need this method and then this
isn't a type yet but we're gonna make
one so let's go make ourselves a cure
worker it's gonna be the thing that
actually does the work all right
a cue worker it makes sense it's this is
going to be the thing that does
everything else it's going to remove
it's going to do the work do they get
the stuff from the queue and things like
that so we're gonna implement I hosted
service right so yep use that and then
controlled out again implement interface
so this is what the interface looks like
it's just start and stop with a
cancellation token
so what the generic host gives us is it
looks takes care of lifecycle like I can
control see this thing name properly
without having to try and handle control
see and stuff like that in my console
application that's already done for you
with like a couple of lines of config
you could switch it over to listen to
window service events so this could
become a window service for example or
that's taken care of you
di config logging is all built in now it
all works exactly the same way it does
in asp net core and this has a type
called background service which we're
actually going to use instead of a
hosted service and it just gives us a
task and a thread to be able to do stuff
on and it takes care of doing start and
stop and when the thing is closing down
it'll call stop it'll give you a chance
to gracefully shutdown then you'll be
done right cool
now BAM look at all that code I'm
amazing so I have a code snippet which
has all the codes you need to talk to
cloud storage because like you've seen
me typing and man taking some time so
let's do this we don't have we don't
have Windows Azure storage I've shown
you as many ways as possible of
installing packages other than the
actual donut CLI so let's continue down
that path and then that'll let us
continue to control that which is the
best way that I like to program is just
control dot until all of my problems are
done we don't have a config but this is
already saying go and grab this
connection string from config here which
is one of the one of the goals of our
comments earlier right was to try and
use config because that seems like a
good idea I've heard occasionally you
want to change things like connection
strings so let's make a constructor by
configuration config let's like make
this underscore config equals config
once again best way to program control
dot your way to glory oh no oh no I did
the wrong control dot oh I'm missing an
eye in this yeah I am that you guys are
great could you guys like just any
chance you guys want to move to Redmond
and just hang out behind me and my desk
when I'm writing code during the day I
think got to be pretty good we call it
extreme pad programming
so we're gonna say ilogger because we
also wanted an ilogger so this works the
same way it does we say call a queue
worker right logger I can parently spell
logo logo let's let's control about this
first you have to control loading the
right order otherwise terrible things
happen right
all right thank you Visual Studio
productivity team all right
now let's walk through real quick what
this code does it's not super
interesting like the point of this talk
isn't to teach you how to use as your
storage queues but I'm gonna give you
like the brief rundown of what we're
doing here so we connect to our storage
account I have an environment variable
with with a connection string to a
storage account already on my machine
which is why I had to go and download
the environment variables config package
we're connecting to we're creating a
queue a connection they've effectively a
client for a queue called worker queue
here that's what this is and then we
have this delay this delay is how long
does it sleep if there's no messages to
process typically in here you probably
want to do some sort of exponential
back-off kind of dealio where like if
you've got no messages overnight you
sleep for a really long time and in the
middle of the day when you've got lots
of messages you don't sleep at all
neither is constantly checking something
like that whatever is appropriate for
your use cases and then we here we say
get me a message and then if there isn't
if there is no message we wait for that
delay period we just talked about
because we're doing stuff pretty simply
here if we fail to process the message
three times this is all standard stuff
for the thing we're just going to delete
it you would probably put it into like a
dead letter Q or a poisoned message
queue or a blob storage or send an email
to the CEO whatever whatever you guys
are going to do then we're just gonna
say we're processing it and then we're
going to delete it and then we're done
and if there's any exceptions it'll be
unbelievable or impossible or something
so BAM what do you think it's gonna work
hmmm what you don't know okay good so
what could you add message hello in DC
BAM
hmm oh look at that hello NDC four
billion dollars in computer science let
me do that it's amazing all right so we
just built a queue worker in the amount
of time has taken me to stand on stage
and you can now say yeah I did it and
it's extensible we could change logging
system whenever we want and the config
system and there's all these conflict
providers we can choose and it is got di
that's amazing and you get to leverage
the ecosystem of stuff that is asp.net
core and don't net core all of the
extensions layer effectively in your own
little private application model right
because that's kind of what you've built
here however it's not really an
application model yet because it's kind
of hard coded right a lot of this stuff
that you're doing in here it's kind of
generic right like all this like talking
to a queue and stuff like that that's
kind of kind of stuff that you've done
we're stuck there like it's stuff that
you're gonna do so if you're gonna I
guess be bet if you are gonna spin up 10
of these 10 different ones different
domains because you're building micro
services you're gonna write this same
code over and over again and I know how
much you guys like writing the same code
over and over again right so what we're
gonna do is and and and as all good
developers we're also trying to find you
know a generic condiment dispenser when
somebody asks us for the sauce so we're
gonna say public class let's call this
queue handler all right what if we could
do this and we could say public void
handle message and we could say what is
this thing called a cloud message or
something or rather the the type was the
type of message sure this thing cloud
queue message nice cloud queue message
message right and then we're gonna say
we're going to put an attribute on this
thing let's control dot this we're gonna
put an attribute on this called it call
a queue Handler and we're gonna give it
a string and we're gonna call a worker
queue all right now I'm gonna control
dot generate this in a new file this is
an attribute and then I'm just gonna
control that again to say I generate a
constructor for me that accepts the cute
it accepts a string
so it looks like this we're gonna change
this to cue name we're gonna rename it
with control dot we'll leave that one as
V because life is too short to change
constructor parameters variables then
I'm gonna put a breakpoint right here
and I'm gonna go back to my cue worker
so what I'm trying to do here some of
you may have already thought ahead what
if by adding you or a hosted service
thing this message but this method got
magically called for every message and
all that other stuff that was common to
everything we did just glad you could
just handle that in a library right yeah
and then you could be then you could be
a framework team sounds great
okay so we're gonna go here we're gonna
go into a queue work our we're gonna go
down to the bottom of the I'm gonna go
to the bottom of the method that's the
method yep I'm gonna go here and I'm
gonna type Bao I'm gonna type faster
than humanly possible and then I'm gonna
controlled on my way to glory and then
I'm gonna explain a whole bunch of what
this code does and then we're gonna
implement our own I you know what every
time I've done this a demo and drive
around this demo I made this same
mistake I forgot to make this public so
what we're gonna do here is let's do
that because otherwise it just like
making that public without doing that
just kind of rubs me the wrong way so
what we've done here is I've defined a
type called queue binding it has the
string which is the name of the queue
we're going to bind to it has a method
info which is the method that's got the
attribute on it and it's got a queue
which is the queue like the library of
the queue client to be able to talk to
the message queue I have a list of them
then I have this method called by and
queue methods it just loops through
every type in the executing assembly
finds every method that has the
attribute on it and adds it to that list
right it's good to be super fast trust
me so we're going to delete this code
that creates a queue client we're gonna
say bind what do we say bind queue
methods we're going to give it the queue
client so that it knows how to create
it's going to use this queue client to
create like the actual you do queue
client create queue client I guess names
names weird to me
do them okay so now in this while loop
we're just looping until the framework
tells us to stop we're gonna say for
each of our binding in underscore Q
bindings we're gonna then at the end of
this while loop we're gonna put in our
closed bracket and then instead of every
where we've got Q we're gonna say
binding dot Q because we've got a Q
there now binding dot here so this is
very basic like a round-robin e type
stuff like I think you would want
something significantly more like
complex than this if you would actually
build something cause like you'll find
this will be really uneven in how it
like distributed stuff across methods
and weird things like that but so now
that's kind of there and here we're
before we were just saying processing me
some data we're gonna do a thing we're
gonna call the method right we could
just effectively what we're doing here
is we're gonna say binding method
binding dot method dot invoke right dot
Evoque but you can't we don't really
want to do that because our new rap
programming model is going to take as
much advantage of our extension stuff as
it can so instead we're going to add a
nice service provider we're going to
call it SP we're gonna make underscore s
P equals SP here so the service provider
is how the DI stuff in asp net core
functions then down here we're going to
say using vast scope equals underscore
SP dot create scope alright and then
once again the answer to all squiggly
zzz control dot and so we're gonna
create a scope so if any of your view
scope services in in in in any of the
other asp net cord on a core stuff what
we're saying here is any scope services
you get a new instance of them for every
message that comes in that's what we're
doing by creating a scope here and so
now what we're gonna do is say activator
utilities we're gonna save our handler
equals activator utilities dot create
instance we're going to give it the
scopes service provider so that it only
has so that it has the scope services
and such then we're gonna the type that
we're going to make is going to be the
binding the method that has that we're
gonna pro handle here it's declaring
type alright and then that's it we're
gonna that'll make
so now what this is going to do is
instantiate the class that that method
is in so now I can do constructor inject
in I could inject an a logger into its
constructor for example and that will
magically work just like it doesn't need
any of your other any can any controller
in asp net call for example then I'm
gonna say binding died method dot invoke
you're gonna use the handler and then
we're gonna give a new like object array
and we're gonna give it the message so
that the message gets passed in then
we're going to build and we're gonna tap
this to this podium for good luck and
we're gonna press f5 and we're gonna
hope it works because life's also too
short for unit tests then we're gonna go
in here and we're gonna add a new
message and we're gonna say yeah like
that and we're gonna say okay and then I
just hit a breakpoint
in my method that has an attribute we
just build a dynamic framework for being
able to you can now give this cue you
could give these two classes its
attribute in this queue worker to
somebody they can over to their project
they implement one of these methods and
bam everything works
they don't even know anything about
queues it's amazing you were the
smartest person in the room right and my
message has yeah just so you have to you
have to get the full effect of the yeah
right yeah that's right
yes that's what I was looking for
okay f5 all right we just build a thing
and it's cool you just got huh you just
build half of ASP out of their car it's
amazing there's lots of more complexity
if you actually try and build something
like this in your in your in your in the
real world but whoa I guess they change
the just they change the keyboard
bindings on me okay
so we built that and we build it in such
a generic way that you not only get to
leverage all of the extensions world
you also could share it with anybody you
want and they could you leverage all of
the extensions world you could now and
now there is also patterns for you to do
things so let's talk about what this is
what I just showed you was a pretty deep
dive into a host of services don't feel
in any way inferior if you didn't
get all that stuff that I just did
there's lots of stuff the point of it
was there's a generic host it has hosted
services it takes care of lifetime so
you takes care of control-c and starting
and stopping the console for me it has
lifetimes for service for Windows
services and being a Linux Dame and
things like that potentially right it
has the Builder pattern that you saw
which is the same as what you would see
in an asp net core application it then
by building a thing using that by
building a thing that uses that
touchscreens you also get access to all
of extensions now extensions is
deliberately designed the reason it's
called extensions are not asp.net core
is it's a significantly broader
cross-cutting concern then what then
what is just than just web so you're
gonna want all of those things down the
side there probably in any application
that you build probably right you don't
necessarily need the I for example but
why not it's great and you can leave
some of this stuff out but in general
you're gonna have di config and logging
and lifetime that's kind of the bare
minimum and then everything else you can
choose to support or not but you also
were then opting to a bunch of patents
if you're if our queue worker needs to
do config that's well known how to do
that you use options and you do it the
same way NBC does it and all of the
stuff that asp net core has those those
questions have been answered for you
there is well-known ways of achieving
that right and then we I hope and
envision this cool set of big frameworks
that build on top of all of that to
provide all sorts of differentiating
value is P net core conceptually
although not actually yet is just a
no-show stood service engineering host
and in the future I hope that's the case
where there is generic host and you go
like ad Kestrel where ad cast through a
hosted service for example and that's
how you move into the kestrel world
already you can add all the links which
is the actor model thing it is built on
generic host and for all of you who were
sitting there going hey this thing that
he's building looks a lot like web jobs
it was exactly like web jobs and you
know what else is built on this now web
jobs so if you take the web jobs SDK the
newest the newest preview of the web
jobs sdk then you can do all this stuff
and you can do it now there's an RC of
the web Jobs SDK for those of you who
aren't aware the web jobs SDK is also
what powers as your functions right so
the new version of that is built on that
generic host it's built the same way
that we just built we just built like a
fifth of it they should pay us right we
just build one of them we just build
that top one for them it was easy
so they they are now boosted on a babe
Dana built and if they have a hosted
service just like the hostess service we
just had it's a lot more complicated a
lot more advanced a lot more
configurable it takes care of all the
edge cases and conditions that I didn't
take care of in my thing just now and
it's and it's battle tested and heart
and such like that I need to let you do
a bunch of this work right so what does
that look like well it looks almost like
this this is an asp net core web
application it's just doing values
controller ignore this see this that I'm
deliberately drawing your attention to
don't look at it okay okay so I'll be
looking here in a minute this is
basically you know how I said you could
do extensions methods with configuration
and stuff some of that stuff isn't quite
there because the core we're best did
your web Jobs SDK other than having a
terrible name because it says web jobs
as your web jobs sdk is its name and you
don't need to be either on Azure or be
using web jobs to be able to use it to
do anything it's it's it's not actually
built just yet to do what I'm about to
do which is to mix it with asp net core
so in this application you know that
queue worker that we had you could add
it to an asp net core app and then you
would have a controller with HTTP and
JSON and a cue worker in the same
process sharing the same loggers sharing
the same business logic services that
you've had so what we're gonna do here
is we're gonna say add web jobs are used
web jobs is the convention use web jobs
and then we're gonna say x dot add as
your storage BAM now we've added web
jobs what this is done is exactly what
our other all this is is an extension
method that in this method it says
service has died add hosted service web
jobs hosted service you know what that
does we just build one
right then the way that their model
works is you make a new class Q worker
all right and then I think I have one
I have web jobs this goes till 640 right
cool okay good okay so this is what a
this is what a web job looks like so
they're programming model there
their model is a little bit different
from ours it's okay we were more
inspired than they were they put the cue
trigger here inside the method right
so this application now if I was to run
it I could put a breakpoint here and I
have this stuff cue open just like I had
the other cue worker open before and
because I am binding just here see that
open the browser because this is an ASP
no core application there is an API
there I can go ping it I can do
controller stuff oh look at that invalid
JavaScript
do you know what that was good job thank
you sir I kind of asked for that okay
and so what I think I'm seeing there is
old messages in the queue what I think I
saw there was an old message in the
queue that had invalid Jason because
about about about half an hour before I
did this talk I swear I completely
forgot how to write Jason and for like a
good three tries I created really really
stupid like released really stupid
entries in this queue and then just kept
going oh yeah that's right oh yeah
that's right oh yeah that's right I
don't know how to write Jason anymore
okay cue worker BAM now the other thing
they do is they deserialize the type so
by putting a JSON string into my message
now magically it's a person object
because that is the magic of web jobs
SDK right so now you actually can use a
supported library to do that thing that
we just we do all that time that we
spent building that thing now that was
important you don't need any of that
okay so we'll use the web jobs SDK so
this and the other thing as you saw here
it's got an ilogger
right you're sharing services these are
the same if I was to take I could take
application environment here same
application environment you'll get in
your controller right like it's all
built in so in this case if you have any
of you read the dotnet micro-services
architecture guidance which is our
delatour's thing some of you are saying
yes one of the things he does there
which is another pattern that you see a
bit is you will have kind of
materialized view in a different service
you have micro service a owns all the
data for a but B kind of needs some of
it so it'll have like a copy in its own
thing and then have this message cube
backplane whenever a changes some data
or it'll put a message on the queue and
then bill update its thing if it seems
appropriate this is the kind this is
this is you might do something like that
this way don't have to by any means
because a micro service doesn't have to
mean the domain of a micro service
doesn't have to be a single process you
could have any way too much domain
modeling this talk is about technologies
and frameworks you could decide to have
an API that takes care of all the data
and it loosens to messages because some
of its data is it really a copy from
someone else's domain and it just
updates it when the other thing tells it
to for example if you wanted to do
something like that
how's that yeah yeah because it's a
generic host app so if it's a Jericho
step you could do that could do that
stuff I've not tried probably not made I
think you should be able to I was a
really good question though yeah I'm the
point of the point like because that web
jobs programming model is really
function so the question becomes like
when do I want to use this instead of
functions right and the answer to that
is when you're not on functions right
you still really want that programming
model but you're not necessarily on
functions if you pay if you've got a
committees the first person that
everybody who falls in love of
kubernetes does it's put everything on
the kubernetes cluster right because
it's magic you might want to serve so
you might want some of those similar
program and what I was all swear right
like in a Windows service for example
and I don't think many people have used
the Windows service stuff you know you
spin in the extensions thing yet but yes
it should work great yeah okay
any questions about that demo anymore
BAM future so we talked about being able
to do which showed you HTTP Jason we
showed you jazz swagger we showed you
HTTP console stuff in the far future
before the probable before the sometime
before the heat death of the universe
there will be transported Gnostic
communication in what is today called
asp net core right
when I started this journey where I said
what does that micro-services cloud
native thing even mean one of the things
I did was go and just look at like every
surf framework I could find that had
said it would had been built
specifically to solve the problems the
developers face when building
micro-services an overwhelmingly common
theme is well I can do G RPC to my
endpoint or I can do HTTP to our gem
point or I could do thrift right it has
like the transport that you're using to
get to your business logic is
independent of the is is able to be
plugged a pluggable and so you'll see
the beginnings of this in signal I have
any of you use the new signal are right
if you use a new signal are over TCP
with Kestrel there's no HTTP in there
right and so that's just an ongoing
effort where we're constantly
refactoring the point to the world where
Kestrel is a connection server it can
take care of doing connections and then
you can have a transport layer on top of
that and some front protocol layers to
be able to have have many different ways
of getting to your load so the first one
of those that I think will probably
start with its G RPC you'll do a lot of
binary stuff and then that'll can lead
to other things MQTT is like completely
different it's weird as strange and it
doesn't even you know we might not even
may not ever get there MQTT is our so
whenever we're going to try and build an
extraction or something we try and build
implementations for that ourselves and
we always try and build something
ridiculous at least one thing that's
ridiculous to try and prove and push the
thing as much as you can
mqtt is our example of that like if we
can implement that it's so different to
everything else we do that it's kind of
means that we've probably done a pretty
good job right now observability is
probably one of the biggest problems
that everybody faces when trying to
declare
not even microservices applications
Diagnostics Diagnostics
like it's so important and one of the
big gaps we have is observability
Diagnostics Diagnostics and basically
I'll be able to stand up every year and
say that same thing and it will still be
true because you can always give you
better and more diagnostics and the most
value we can give you is a consistent
way of getting and accessing all of
those and getting access to all of that
for all of the ops for all of your
services one of the big pains that
Netflix has Netflix had when they did a
more much more polyglot stuff across all
the Netflix micro services was well all
these different languages now have
different kind of ways we have to
standardize for ops we everybody needs
to do like logging the same thing and
now the metrics do the same thing right
we need to consent relies some stuff
because we need to manage some of this
right to some extent and so in the
future I think that we're gonna do a lot
of work on metrics I say I think here
because now this is committed in any in
any way yeah this is what I think that
I'm gonna try and leave the team to do
in the future a big push for metrics
being able to get those to Prometheus
all those sorts of things a big push for
distributed tracing there's already a
bunch of distributed tracing stuff you
can do
it's Bhosle tied to application insights
but a lot of the primitives are there so
make that better one of the things that
we have today that's kind of a problem
is if you if you dude if you're doing
distributed tracing and ie talks to be
talks to C and B isn't like enabled for
a distributor tracing you lose the
context because it's not passing it
along right there's some of there's a
few of you who were like moved to
speaking out in a talk because of that
which is great that can be a problem so
like you know try and make that easier
so we just always flow those things if
we see them some people at Microsoft and
Google have partnered up I'm and a bunch
of others they program the Google and
Microsoft guys started up and a bunch of
other people join and they created a w3c
community working group to form a paper
like a spec for what a distributed
tracing context should look like so
we're gonna do a bunch of work to try
and like implement that and support that
and like we want to see things like I've
been tracing exists and things like that
right
damn so in 2.2 we did a lot of work for
some stuff called end points and end
point routing if you see any slides and
say like hey routing got faster you got
faster kind of as a side effect of doing
a bunch of work to move routing down so
some people that try and do micro
service as I have not super common but
fairly regularly some wooly login issues
say I don't want to use MVC I don't care
about be like I hate Vee stop putting V
in my program like I don't want the V
from MVC there's no V's in my
application anywhere why am I writing
that that seems done and then Fowler
will endeavor variably say why don't we
just rename it why don't we just add
another thing that does exactly the same
thing and call it something else so then
I'll stop loading messages but what
those people are trying assists kind of
saying is there's stuff from MVC you
want in all of your applications not
necessarily all of it and some of the
biggest parts of that is routing so
today routing is only really happens at
the news MVC part of your middleware
pipeline in the future
middleware will be able to know about
routes and where routes are going to go
so through how many of you have done
cause with your API today the cross
origin request stuff right have you did
you do middleware and then realize you
needed an attribute and then you went oh
okay and then you did it in two places
yeah there's at least there's a couple
of guys nodding yeah that'll go away
with this because the middleware will be
able to do everything because it'll know
about the stuff from MVC the reason you
go do it in two places because MVC knows
about MVC and routes and the middleware
does not right this is kind of a never a
pass one possible future of where that
could lead
if if routing is core like core in the
firt in in in a very small layer on top
of generic host you can start doing
stuff like this
there's no MVC in this it's just mapping
it's just routing to code right you can
do some stuff you could do stuff you can
do syntax like this today but not like
built this way with this sort of
performance characteristics I expect
this will have I've got no actual idea
this is a complete vaporware it was
written copy and pasted it from an email
from a design meetings like summary
and then you could maybe even do
something like this where you say map me
a service this is the type of my service
require authorization it's an API mat
and map get and then MBC could then play
in this world where sometimes you'll go
to NBC maybe you go to razor pages maybe
you go to this service eking up here
right it seems great so that's a that's
a that's a more future thinking thing as
well
probably so for all of these for these
two and for any for that routing stuff
probably like a three-hour time frame if
I get my way and with that I am Glenn
Condren I have been your host this
evening you've been a wonderful audience
thank you very much and I didn't think I
would do it but I finished two minutes
early so all of the questions that have
been simmering in your brain for this
whole time you can ask them and I will
answer to the best of my ability and if
there are none well you would like to
come up or see me later on around the
conference just come up and talk to me
in person and I will talk to you don't
be don't be scared yeah
absolutely so I didn't make a point of
this you could build gr PC today not
built on any of that extension stuff
that we've seen if you go make a gr PC
up completely different to any a any
like of the.net core app you've built
anywhere you should have asked me while
everybody was here so I could have
remembered to say that but yeah so we
don't intend to replace that it's we
intend to provide an alternative an in
fact we've already started talks with
the guys who work on the.net version of
G RPC that work at Google because what
it is is if you just want like really if
you just want what geo pcs got great it
should be there and you should be able
to use it
their thing uses their own native web
server we want ours to use kestrel we
want it to be integrated with extensions
we want di we want configuration we want
login we want all that stuff there's not
going to provide that so if we want that
we have to do it that's what I want from
the G RPC work stream that make sense
sound good yeah what about them you can
use them you know there's no metrics
support in asp net core we don't give
you any metrics so you can use
Prometheus but I don't know what you'll
send there you send your own metrics I
guess how many when how many times is
the GC run what is the how many requests
per seconds are you doing how many
exceptions have you had what is the
internals of system what is the system
doing what is asp net core doing that's
what I mean by we will provide will I
want to will provide like internally a
mechanism for metrics to flow we will
put stuff on to it and we'll make you
either say you could put stuff on it and
we'll provide an easy mechanism to get
it into Prometheus yeah yeah yeah that's
right yeah
yeah it'll all be built on all that tech
right and I think a lot of the plumbing
for that is actually already being built
now it just doesn't really have a way to
get it out of proc right now the lower
levels are already working on it cuz it
takes a lot to time for them to move and
there's a bunch of interesting problems
right like if you want to take stats
around if you want to take stats from
the GC you can't do it while the GC is
running because GC just kills everything
so the GC has to like stash it somewhere
that somewhere else can get it the GC
he's not going to see like no so the
time so the today and tomorrow issues
all stuff that's happening in kind of 2
1 to 2 for the most part which half
times the rest of it no it's probably
300 but I don't have any real anything
more specific than anybody else but most
of the stuff we've talked about for 3 oh
so far has been with Windows forms and
stuff like that this is stuff I hope to
including that wave but I also have no
commitment or plan for it so we'll see
I see so that depends right like that
depends on when you need it and I don't
think that I don't think that any of
your work would be made useless by
anything that we do it would should only
be enhancing because anything that you
do is mostly going to be capturing your
own metrics and there's nothing we're
gonna do that's gonna make that probably
not much that we get we might they might
there might be a slightly different or
better ways for you to be able to log
them if you're still gonna have to do
all the same work to kind of capture the
metrics and stuff so I wouldn't think so
I think so I guess the answer to that
was like yeah it's probably a fire to
keep investigating it I don't think
waiting for us will will give you that
much more value I can yeah I can publish
the slides and the sample projects I'll
tweak them when I do at Condren G is my
Twitter account if any of you want them
because I didn't plan for that ahead of
time I didn't think anybody would want
them it's not my project that that was a
like that's if that's an open source
library it's not mine from n swag yeah
yeah we talked about building our own
swagger generation library if there is
if there's a thing we want lots of
people to use but there are already is
there's already obvious and obvious and
small number of really good projects out
there that we can just tell people to
use and the guidance is pretty simple
then doesn't we don't we we won't build
a competitor which means in general
which means that we will build stuff so
we built API we wanted we wanted better
swagger generation we could have built
our own swagger library instead what we
did was build a thing called API
Explorer and we did a lot of work so
those conventions that you saw for
example they add metadata they add data
to the API Explorer and we went and
worked with all the swagger author
libraries to be able to get they
from API Explorer so that their swagat
got better as a side-effect of us doing
work on this thing without us actually
having to build our own like swagger gen
and it's the same for client gen when
client gen becomes a thing it'll be in
swag that does qui and Jenny won't be it
won't be us and it'll be and it'll be
it'll probably auto arrest and in swag
we'll be the two options so make sense
yeah I'll be here - any more questions
that come to you grab me at any time I'm
more than happy to talk to you about all
sorts of nerdy and geeky things
especially if it involves Thundercats
yeah